que de la tôle sous le soleil d'autant
lusine tolix a ouvert ses portes ce week
end pour le plus grand plaisir des
acheteurs qui n'ont pas hésité à remplir
leurs stocks avec des produits locaux
pour moi c'est une grande marque et puis
surtout je suis au dessus de moi
d'origine donc ça m'aurait a fait un
petit peu suez d'avoir de la contrefaçon
est pas de pas de l'original on trouve
toutes les couleurs à tous les prix et
puis en plus c'est une usine qui a
autant on chez autunoise donc c'est
c'est super chouette de faire travailler
une usine du coin
ce qui attire d'abord des clients ce
sont les prix jusqu'à -70% sur certains
modèles
de quoi se faire plaisir comme stéphanie
très très bon prix 4 qu'est ce que ça
vaut normalement
donc voilà je contente autre atout la
diversité des modèles vendus vintage
moderne gris usées ou rouge pétant la
palette des choix est large et certaines
pièces sont vendues totalement neuve
d'autres totalement rouillé comme celle
que vous voyez à côté de moi mais plus
le produit a deux défauts - il est chère
celle ci est à 189 euros alors que celle
ci est à 100 euros de man et ses prix ne
rebute pas les fans de tolix plus d'une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
dès la première heure ce succès réjouit
la pdg du groupe
car lorsqu'elle a racheté l'entreprise
en 2004 tolix manqué de s'effondrer
j'espère que l'entreprise va perdurer
très très très longtemps
c'est vrai qu'elle a eu des difficultés
dans un temps mais bon là j'ai fait
beaucoup d'innovations
je suis entré la couleur on a une équipe
qui recherche qui améliorent et nuit je
suis très confiante tolix compte
aujourd'hui 85 employés et est en phase
de recrutement
de quoi entretenir l'espoir d'un bel
avenir pour la tôle made in autant